こんにちはンドーったはじめなお前等興味深い本を見つけた
そうこちらです恐竜発掘人影トレからトップス地人力
すぎだね謎砂の中から恐竜が出てくるらしいです
スコッチとこって kk 中にみんな
まあ計10人の中負けずに計10人
まあ軽巡
委員の中からまあ計10人の12人
負け準備に中から場所取りが出てくるわけだそう簡単ですねが明けて開けると中に砂が
入ってそっから発掘するらしいです
僕は仕事は分からないんですけどもマーボかな恐竜博士と呼ばれていない
まあ距離に関してはねもうヅラ期からサッカーきますねなんでも
ていますさあ何だ安居ないのとかもまあ卒中で食事でてますよ
うん
じゃあ開いてみますはこれで大可賀動画で出してたねあーこんな感じでございます
ですね2つグラスとヘラですねこれを使ってコースだから化石を発掘くるってことでも
入れました
こちらですもうすぐなうでございますこの制度の中にさっきの墓住民のながら人にバグ
が入ってるわけ
コレアがすごいことになるでしょうからぜひ来まし
となんかもドーン金の人みたいな数字に村存知の引いておりますサスを挙げてみ
ましょう
こんなにバカになって言ってんだよなーすげー南春日積んだね
この食べてるのかな食べれたら嬉しいな
朝べちゃダメなんだこれがね関係感想止まった最高にハッピーな部分
じゃあさっそくやって言ってます
[音楽]
うあ
me
ni
[音楽]
[拍手]
まあ科学技術でしょ今の最先端の技術を使えばこんなのも一発家に入りますチランド
サウルスって待って
こちらのサーブですかうちらがサーブじゃねえ広場さんですかアトレー4番を強い
サービス
ちぎえおましゅんがドロスじゃん強気で終わりと結構可愛いです実は俺結構恐竜も好き
なんですよぜひ
普通にやってみてくださいじゃーん
じゃ